well that's a very physically demanding
you ever see the Keanu Reaves footage no
he's training for John wick to now
please God make John wick three runnin
through Times Square on a horse shooting
people in the head in John wick three
yeah they're doing it you haven't seen
that no well show the footage first of
all the training footage for John why
John wick - man that [ __ ] Keanu
Reeves he gets into it yeah he was
training with my friend he get Machado
in jujitsu so they do Roboto No here yes
I'll get him give me some volume so like
when you watch him shoot ya in the movie
he looks very comfortable shooting and
even his martial arts like the stuff
that he's doing in the movie it's
legitimate like it's it's doable it's
real he's really training oh yeah
I mean he's not doing anything where you
go get that like right there's no road
house moves like last night I love road
have I got home from the comedy store
last night and I was gonna go to sleep
but Roadhouse's I'm like I'm staying up
I stayed up it's the best going in the
bar I watched it an hour and a half and
until he killed the guy by grabbing his
neck and that's when I have it closely
um you missed the big end scene in the
house so he's on a horse in John wick 3
Wow
he's the real deal a Tom Cruise just get
him back on the Chevelle why are you
giving him horse he's Tom Cruise the
1970 Chevelle is the way to go not a
[ __ ] horse come on so he trains like
legit shooting trains legit shooting
legit martial arts Senator Jackson isn't
it oh my god what Samuel Jackson not in
is there a list of it's like 10 films
being an actor until he was late in his
career really oh yeah how old was he
I want to say 40 but I feel like I might
be mixed with some truth that might be
Rodney Dangerfield yeah the original
John wick is a [ __ ] great movie in
John wick twos a great movie they're
both great I watched two of them back to
back
on a plane recently so that the one
where everything's on fire and that one
scene where he's like coming out of an
apartment John went to one when he's
not Ruby Rose check is a fight with Ruby
Rose hilarious girl power save it I take
such a good punch yeah Kiana's pulling
punches yeah
he's legit Tom Cruise he trains and does
all his real stuff yeah Tom Cruise does
a lot of crazy stuff right yeah he
[ __ ] up his ankle jumping off of a
building to another building
yeah climbing on the outside of planes
hanging on does all that stupid [ __ ]
yeah
car chases he does that and those of
themselves ya know in Dubai hanging off
this end of that building okay yeah he's
a maniac he is a maniac